mon père qui avait été fermé par eux
décida de confier mon éducation au père
jésuite fondateur à bordeaux d'un
collège baptisé saint-joseph tivoli il
me faut les remercier ses jésuites de
m'avoir rendu touche-à-tout et férus
d'humanité pour aborder le journalisme
d'un coeur pur et d'une plus légère il
ya quelques petites impertinence et et
vacheries dans mon livre sur les
jésuites et sur l'enseignement que j'ai
reçues sur la la la la la qualité si on
veut dire le brillant de l'enseignement
je trouve qu'ils n'étaient pas mais le
l'atmosphère humaine était excellent
quel enfant bordelais né quelque part
sur ses bords de garonne hérisset de
grands filets pourrait être surpris en
doublant le cap saint jacques pour
entrer dans la rivière de saigon en
longeant le mississippi en franchissant
le stanley poule en découvrant le mékong
du côté de plan de peine
mais n'anticipons pas je crois que nous
autres bordelais nous avons quand même
une sorte de propension naturelle une
une sorte de mission spontanée à aller à
aller au loin cette aune ou quand même
nous projette vers l'extérieur vers la
carrière de la ville de bordeaux c'est
comme une carrière largement coloniale
et et notre vin après tout notre vin il
voguait vers l'angleterre notre vin est
devenu illustré est respectée en grande
partie parce que château l'a conduit
vers les îles britanniques
les prouvait le sentiment du beau au
théâtre de louis où l'on donnait à
tabliers les femmes savantes je sens
encore crise et sous mes ongles le
velours rouge de l'accoudoir un peu râpé
et le léger vertige que j'ai prouvé au
deuxième balcon en lorgnant avec émoi le
corsage des soubrettes de marivaux mon
père est un chirurgien
théâtre avec des billets gratuits et bon
j'étais pas du tout mais gérable j'ai eu
une enfance assez facile mais tout de
même l'argent de poche étaient allés au
théâtre d'été quand je payais c'était
assez cher que j'avais des billets
gratuits pour l'opéra je veux je vous
jure je suis assez calé je connais très
bien le répertoire de répertoire de
l'opéra d'ailleurs je suis membre du
conseil d'administration de l'opéra de
paris d'ailleurs alors jean lacouture on
vous laisse avec vos souvenirs d'enfance
et on vous laisse aller à l'intérieur de
ce beau grand théâtre merci merci ca ma
bouche et vous